[Music]
who is making this stuff
who's allowing this to happen
as far as fakes go they're pretty good
i mean i'd buy them
don't be such a [ __ ]
don't call me [ __ ] sweetie
that's not what i said i asked you not
to be one
this is serious
and you're laughing it off at least it's
my name on the mugs not yours
our name
sweetie
on jack
it was a name that sounded so sweet so
seductive come meet the family everybody
this is patricia and this is my family
[Music]
they had it all
worth
style power who wouldn't care for that
[Music]
but it's you my nephew i've been a gucci
all my life
it is an empire
you can help the family which is not
exciting and everybody knows it at least
it's my name sweetie
our name
sweetie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is what i say is
this is not a woman's game
remember that
madness who does it
it's time to take out the trash
gucci is a rare animal
you must be protected
protected from homelessness
from whoever threatens it
[Music]
who does what
oh
[Music]
don't
miss
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't consider myself for particularly
ethical person no but i am fair
i subscribe to
unconventional punishments
[Music]
you